for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so previously we saw that ammonium
ion could be transported safely from
tissues to the liver by way of glooming
glutamine being the main sort of amino
acid that carries nitrogen through the
blood and around the body
now that doesn't have to happen
exclusively with glutamine it can also
occur with another amino acid alanine
and that alanine is specifically coming
from the skeletal muscles okay so what's
gonna be going down is that in the
muscle we're gonna be breaking down
proteins and will basically take amino
groups as breaks creating the amino
groups from the muscle out through the
blood to the liver and we're gonna have
a little cycle here we're gonna see what
that's gonna look like okay so we'll
start off in a skeletal muscle cell
we'll make our way through the blood and
eventually to the liver so let's start
here in the skeletal muscle cell with
glucose so in these skeletal muscle cell
we're gonna be talking about taking
glucose and metabolizing it to pyruvate
via baikal assessed once we get that
pyruvate that pyruvate will undergo a
transamination reaction catalyzed by
alanine aminotransferase and the reason
it's named alanine aminotransferase is
because it's gonna turn that pyruvate
into alanine because alanine is the
alpha amino acid counterpart to pyruvate
being an alpha keto acid so where's that
amino group coming from well it's coming
from the transamination reaction
specifically from glutamate where is
that glutamate coming from well we're
breaking down proteins in the skeletal
muscle into amino acids and of course
those amino acids have nitrogens on them
those will end up on glutamate and that
glue to make it supply that nitrogen for
this amino transferase reaction and so
what we're gonna do is we're basically
taking this nitrogen here that's from
the breakdown product from those
proteins and tacking it on to pyruvate
to make alanine now that alanine that's
produced can be sent in the blood
through to deliver and once it's in the
liver and will basically undergo that
same amino transferase reaction that
same transamination reaction to get
pyruvate back and what happens to that
amino group
well it's undergoing the this whole
thing is happening in the as a
transamination reaction opposite what
occurred in the skeletal muscle cell
that Alan II will be turning it at
pyruvate and this amino group will end
up being attached to alpha ketoglutarate
to produce glutamate except how that
glutamate is in the liver so now what
can happen with that glutamate is it can
be you can undergo the glutamate
dehydrogenase steps to free up that
ammonium ion which of course can be
excreted safely as urea after going
through the urea cycle or that nitrogen
could be used to supply transamination
reactions to produce a sparked eight
which can also go through the through to
the urea cycle the point is though that
we're basically getting the nitrogen
that are there that are sort of the
products of breaking down proteins and
the muscles out into the liver right so
we're taking let's do that in a
different color we're taking these guys
out through the blood and to the liver
so they can eventually be excreted
safely in urea now this is the whole
situation that we're talking about is
the glucose alanine cycle but I haven't
actually talked about a cycle quite yeah
I'm finished it I've just talked about
it one way going from the skeletal
muscle to the liver once this pyruvate
is produced in the liver it can undergo
gluconeogenesis to produce glucose which
can be sent back to the skeletal muscle
via the blood right so that that glucose
can be broken down for energy in the
skeletal muscle cell so the point here
basically is that the ammonium ion from
extra paddock tissues is not only
transported by glutamine that's one
point here also it muscle tissue alanine
can do the job especially because this
contributes to getting glucose back to
the muscle tissue so that that's go
what's a tissue can can go through and
metabolize that for energy now this
might this sort of schematic might look
kind of familiar kind of the muscle and
liver kind of with a cycle if you recall
there is another cycle the Cori cycle
that is a sort of similar thing though
this works well with the Cori cycle
basically to get glucose back to
metabolically active tissue and we're
kind of killing two birds with one stone
and in addition to doing that you're
getting the nitrogen out from the
skeletal muscle to a liver to be
detoxified okay so that's basically the
glucose alanine cycle I hope that video
was helpful thank you for watching if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying